because
you know
i know
you know what's coming next
hey guys pete here it's week two of lalo
haunting everyone who's ever met him in
our main story when you try to pull off
a big plan it's important to know your
enemy but what about when your enemy
knows you howard knows who's behind the
latest attempt to destroy his reputation
and gus knows that lalo can't move
forward with his plan until he has the
blessing of the cartel two different
worlds two different chess matches and
since this is a prequel two different
sets of stakes this was not my favorite
episode of better call saul's final
season to sit through but they are
setting up some fascinating maneuvering
on both sides of the story we'll get
into all of that right after this quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
better call saul season 6 episode 5 yet
then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
before this season started it was hard
to imagine gus losing his cool let alone
breaking under pressure now it's hard to
imagine a scenario where he doesn't put
a definitive end to the threat that is
lalo before this season concludes
because he can't be the character we
know from breaking bad and still be this
worried about him in black and blue we
see him trying to distract himself from
the threat by going about his normal
business at his restaurant you see him
check his ankle holster before going out
front and then see that he's completely
distracted while dealing with a customer
this has all been building up since he
knocked over the glass a few episodes
ago and when he goes outside and looks
into the distance here you can see that
he's starting to crack later mike is
snuck into his house to tell him that
there's still no news and that it's
become a waiting game this not knowing
is what is really getting to gus his
lack of control over the situation him
using his time to clean the grout in the
bathroom with a toothbrush is a great
illustration of this they visit the
superlab site where mike reassures him
that no one can get inside gus then goes
and has a look around he finds a marker
on a cord that's laying on the ground
and counts off paces to a spot where he
stashes a gun at first this feels like a
backup plan just in case lalo discovers
the lab but if you think about it this
is probably him taking back some control
he knows that lalo needs to discover
this place as proof to show that he's
acting against the cartel so what if he
just uses that against him and we'll
come back around to this at the end
after i finish the recap kim's attempt
to take back control at three in the
morning is a little less dramatic but
it's coming from the same place putting
a chair under the door handle is fairly
useless but you have to think of
something when you're so worried you
can't sleep jimmy is lucky and that he
still believes lalo's dead but he still
can't shake off the fear either he gives
kim the perfect opportunity to let him
in on the secret but she decides that
keeping him in the dark is the best
course of action this is interesting
since they could be going through this
together and it does make you wonder
about her motivation is it what mike
said is she worried it will break him
more or is she just concerned with his
being able to play his part in their
continued assault on howard i'm not sure
if she knows just like i'm not sure how
she feels about what viola tells her
when they meet up at the el camino she
starts out there with an apology for how
she left schweikart because she imagines
her old assistant had to clean up some
of the mess then we find out that viola
has been moved from the mesa verdi
account to sandpiper when kim casually
mentions she'd heard that too we
understand that this isn't a social
visit that she set the meeting to try to
gather some information she does get
some of that she finds out who the judge
on their first mediation session is and
then the conversation turns to how much
viola admires what kim's doing sometimes
she questions all of what she does and
thinks it's great that kim could walk
away from that to help the little guy
when she says she makes her feel better
about the law kim gives her a
half-hearted smile and takes a sip of
her coffee sort of looking away it's all
a good reminder of what they're risking
in trying to push the settlement ahead
and the disconnect between how people
see kim compared to what she's currently
doing and just how unnecessary taking
down howard seems
we get to see him in his glory when he
picks up the ball that aaron fumbled at
sandpiper and runs with it he's able to
convince his clients the tenants there
who are all getting tired of waiting for
this settlement that it's worth it and
this is impressive considering their age
and the fact that they don't have
forever to wait what's funny is that
cliff had noticed some nervous energy as
he was bouncing his leg in his seat
before he stood up and so he takes this
moment to confront him about having a
drug problem it gets better when howard
who can't believe what he's hearing
denies it but cliff's been primed by his
attic sons lying so he doesn't believe
him he tells them there's no harm in
asking for help and by this point howard
has put it all together in typical
howard fashion he stops to thank him for
his concern since he knows he came to
him as a friend and it must have been
hard and then tells him he doesn't have
a drug problem he has a jimmy mcgill
problem he excuses himself to make a
phone call and then delivers one of the
best howard lines ever when he tells his
secretary to cancel his week we catch up
with jimmy's continuing transformation
into saul as he fills francesca in on
all the changes that have been going on
since he last saw her yes there's no
more kim and he's standing in the middle
of an office that is just one step up
from a burn out abandoned building but
he's really busy and willing to double
her salary with an additional signing
bonus i love that she drove up listening
to a wilson phillips song that is 15
years old in the show's timeline and
that she negotiated to have a say in the
decorating that point is curious
considering we know what this office
ends up looking like and it makes you
wonder because it always seemed like she
had been worn down by her time with saul
when we first meet her in the main
series her quick negotiating skills here
seem to be consistent with other
instances where we saw her extracting
cash from people so maybe there's more
to francesca than meets the eye later
that night she sends jimmy to a boxing
gym to meet a potential new client named
mr ward it turns out to be howard who
challenges them to a boxing match this
is a meeting that we knew was coming
from the trailers and i honestly never
thought that there would be any actual
boxing but there is and it's an awkward
affair which is kind of why i didn't
think it would happen the way it's shot
points out the ridiculousness like
there's how it looks in your head when
you hand jimmy a beating and then
there's what it really looks like which
is what we see here and i guess that's
an interesting point to make even if
it's not a lot of fun to watch what's
more interesting here is what they say
to each other of course howard was
always going to figure out jimmy was
behind this and he points out that they
didn't even try to cover their tracks
which he thinks means that they were
trying to get caught after it's over he
tells him that he's mistaken his
kindness for weakness and that he'd like
to think that this would be enough that
this would be the end but he doesn't
believe that's the case when he goes
outside he meets with his private
investigator telling him that he needs
to know everyone that he talks to and
everywhere he goes and when jimmy leaves
we see him follow him this brings up a
lot of questions because we know that
mike has people following jimmy that he
never noticed there's potential here
that mike's guys will notice howard's
guys or vice versa and that their two
worlds will come in contact with each
other kim's waiting at home and there's
a nice shot where she smiles as she
watches jimmy pull up and then that
drops whenever she sees that he's
holding ice on his head inside she
catches him up on what happened with
viola and shows him a picture of the
judge he makes a remark about liking his
handlebar mustache and that might be a
hint that they're going to try to
impersonate him what stood out the most
here was that neither one of them was
concerned at all about howard figuring
out that they were behind everything
that's happened to him this lines up
with my theory that it was part of their
plan and they added a little bit more to
think about at the gym he had a chance
to walk away and just leave howard
unsatisfied but he chose to go back and
take him up on the fight he makes a
point of saying he didn't know what he
was thinking and kim tells him that he
had his reasons she says it was because
he knows what's coming next and to me
this made it sound like he has guilt
over what they're about to do she grabs
his hand to comfort him as they turn out
the light and even though he's become a
willing participant fully on board with
making this work this reinforces that
she's still the one pulling the strings
i haven't mentioned the opening teaser
yet and considering what it turned out
to be i'm not at all surprised that i
totally misinterpreted what was
happening in those scenes from the
trailer it turns out verner's crew had
his slide rule encased in resin or
something like that and gave it to his
wife as a gift we saw him pull this out
of his bag in his first appearance when
he was looking at the laundry site with
mike this turns out to be important when
lalo shows up in germany to track mrs
ziegler down he's back and he's smooth
as ever as he makes the approach and
gets information about her husband over
drinks if you watch these scenes out of
context you would have no idea what was
going on with this character he's
completely at home in this situation he
coaxes out the cover story that her
husband died in a cabin but can't learn
more about what they were building
because she doesn't know he nearly
seduces her he does walk her home but
she doesn't invite him in even after he
tells her he's flying back tomorrow he
waits all night until he sees her leave
for work the next morning and then
sneaks into the house i don't know about
anyone else because this was a tense
sequence but my real fear here was that
he was gonna kill the dog they
introduced little bear when they
approached the house and knowing this
character and what he's capable of it
just didn't seem like he was safe much
to my relief his charms extend to the
animal kingdom and he's even able to
calm this little guy speaking a foreign
language he looks around the house and
doesn't find anything useful and the
tension reaches a new level when
marguerite comes back to get her phone
the dog alerts her that something is
wrong and lola gets his gun ready as she
approaches the steps while he's
considering his options he sees the
slide rule and connects it to what she
said about his workers sending keepsakes
rather than attending the funeral the
translation of the inscription reads
with love your boys and he notices that
the company that made its name is on the
bottom he can use that to find out who
commissioned the piece and then go to
them for answers about what they were
working on he does one of his super lolo
moves and leaves out of the second floor
window which frauzeegler finds open when
she comes in that room if he killed her
it probably would have set off some
alarms inside gus's organization and
since lalo doesn't know that he thinks
he's still alive this one about as good
as he could hope little bear and
marguerite will both live to see another
day and the episode ends as she closes
the window which is the mirror image of
the way that the opening teaser started
it was good to get some lolo and there's
some interesting stuff going on but as i
mentioned at the beginning this wasn't
my favorite episode of the season it's
probably my least favorite the pacing
was similar to last week but i thought
the wendy keeper was a lot funnier than
the fight and was more interested in the
character development in that one i
think the prequel factor has a lot to do
with it gus being paranoid is just not
that interesting because we know he
comes out on top of this situation the
interesting part of that is how he'll
manage to pull it off and of course that
does require setup his going to the lab
and taking back some control felt
necessary and it appears that he's
putting a plan together though i wasn't
a hundred percent on what they were
going for when he got distracted at los
pollos it was right after he mentioned
the signature spice curls and that made
me think of the magical meeting last
season when he first introduced those i
guess this was the first step in him
putting it together that lala would
pursue the germans then he can somehow
lead him to the site through them the
way he placed the gun it made it seem
like it was part of a plan or a trap
even but it's not clear how he's
planning to lure lalo in yet the other
thing that is starting to wear on me a
little is that they're keeping us behind
the characters as far as what they're
planning this started with them cutting
away from their conversation at the el
camino in the first episode and now
they've planned out this whole operation
without letting us in on any of the
details our being in the dark should
make for some good reveals but it also
lessens my investment last week when we
saw kim and jimmy alone i felt like we
were getting insights as to what they
were thinking this week i just kept
thinking that i didn't know what they
were up to that said the kim and viola
scene was really good i liked how she
was bringing up all this stuff that was
in direct conflict with what kim is
actually doing at the moment and they
did manage to develop howard some in his
discovering what they were up to when i
was making my howard video the other day
i realized just how much we don't know
about this character so it was good to
see that they put some layers there and
i'm curious to see how they proceed now
that he's actively fighting back the pi
thing seems like it could create real
problems and could even be the thing
that brings the two stories together
some in lalo's absence that does not
seem good for howard who exists in a
place that's a comfortable distance from
any cartel activity i just can't really
see how that might be something that
would improve his situation so all in
all it was mostly set up with an
injection of charm and menace from south
of the border i really like what they're
doing with everyone anticipating their
enemies next move but wish we had more
of an idea of what they're thinking i
have full confidence that it'll add to
the impact of what's to come and can't
wait to see what that is there's two
more to go before the mid-season break i
expect that things will pick up from
here and i think that's a good place to
leave things
let me know in the comments what you
think about this episode and where you
think things will go from here we'll be
getting together for the live stream on
tuesday night at 9 00 pm eastern to dig
in a little deeper so come join us for
that and make sure to bring your
questions please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon